an electric car is great for zipping
around the city but it's no good for
long distance that's the assumption evie
makers are trying to prove wrong and
Chevy wants to do it with the bolt an
affordable electric car that's supposed
to go 200 miles on a charge this
long-awaited evie for the hoi polloi is
just about rec and to put it to the test
I climbed into a pre-production bolt for
a test drive down the California coast
from Monterey to San Luis Obispo to
Santa Barbara by dinnertime I had
covered a whopping 240 miles the range
estimator promised another 20 if I
wanted to keep going the bolt doesn't
just beat the 200 mile mark it stumps
the 210 mile range of Tesla's Model S 60
the $50,000 luxury sedan and it gives
chevy sole ownership of a new segment
the long range affordable electric color
at least until tesla catches up with its
feature stuffed model 3 the bolt is a
genuinely nice car it's got lots of leg
room a 10.2 inch touchscreen even a
special spot to hold your phone
affordable and it can go the distance
looks like Chevy's about to change some
minds
you